nous recevons ce soir jean marie
burguburu il est avocat président de la
commission nationale consultative des
droits de l'homme
en ces temps de restriction de liberté
et de droits humains parfois bafouée
beaucoup de sujets vont nous intéresser
avec lui on a choisi de se concentrer
d'abord sur la situation des prostituées
il y a cinq ans une loi changer
complètement la donne la personne qui se
prostituaient n'était plus considérée
comme délinquantes mais comme victime
d'un système et c'était le client qui
devait être puni beaucoup ont cru que
c'était une bonne chose que ça
faciliterait la vie des prostituées mais
pour certaines pas pour tout temps mais
pour certaines c'est tout l'inversé qui
s'est produit ces seuls 6 ou les a
rencontrés témoignages maria à vingt
cinq ans elle est une ancienne
prostituée
grâce à une amie il y a deux ans elle a
frappé à la porte de l'amicale du nid
une association qui l'a aidé à s'en
sortir
elle a rencontré sarah sa référente à
qui elle a pu raconter son histoire
aujourd'hui j'ai incité chant bien
parce que mon insistance et ciel avec
des mois pour sortir emplissent la donne
et moi le courage pour dire j'ai bel
vivait en france
ici je fais pas prostitution
maintenant j'ai senti bien parce que
déjà va plus dans la rue pour l'extraire
des réseaux de proxénétisme
l'association a trouvé un logement
d'urgence à marjah elle accompagne aussi
dans ses démarches administratives à
proposer un accompagnement global en
fait sur la question de la santé la
formation l'emploi
tout ce qu'ils ont peut on travaille
avec une juriste qui qui va pouvoir nous
étayée sur tout ce qui est dépôt de
plainte par exemple si les dames veulent
déposer plainte contre leur proxénète
depuis la loi prostitution de 2016 les
victimes de réseaux comme maria
bénéficier d'une allocation de 330 euros
par mois mais aussi une autorisation de
séjour de six mois renouvelable quatre
fois une avancée pour delphine jarreau
déléguée générale de l'amicale du nid
cca levier très puissant
puisqu'en fait l'extrême majorité des
40000 personnes adultes en situation de
prostitution en france sont sans titre
de séjour est donc évidemment un titre
une autorisation provisoire de séjour
est un levier puissant pour accéder à
des formations pour accéder à l'emploi
autre changement de la loi de 2016 c'est
désormais le client qui est pénalisé et
non la prostituée chaque année près de
1300 personnes sont verbalisés pas
suffisant pour l'amicale du nid qui
souhaitent aller plus loin on
souhaiterait des campagnes nationales
qui sensibilise sur le fait que la
victime
c'est la personne situation prostitution
l'auteur de violences
l'acheteur est que des gamins dès le
plus jeune âge à la conscience qu'on
n'achète pas le corps d'un être humain
un avis qui n'est pas partagé par amar
travailleuses du sexe depuis 11 ans avec
260 et une autre prostituée elle a
déposé un recours pour abolir la loi
devant la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme
pour elle la pénalisation du client a
aggravé les conditions de travail
des prostituées depuis avril 2016 en
fait ce que nous on a remarqué c'est
qu'il y avait de plus en plus de
situations de violence parce que vous
avez une loi en pénalisant les clients
ou les bains finalement les clients veut
ce sens vont se sentir moins ou vont
avoir peur en fait de solliciter nos
services on va avoir moins de clients et
donc on va être dans des situations on
va être obligé entre guillemets de
retenir certains clients qu'on n'aurait
pas forcément retenue dans des
situations on avait pleinement le choix
autre effet collatéral de cette loi 90 %
des rencontres entre prostituées clients
ont lieu dans des endroits cachés
difficile dans ces conditions de repérer
les victimes des réseaux qui
contrairement à hamar n'ont pas fait le
choix de la prostitution
allons plus loin avec vous jean marie
burguburu bienvenus vous êtes avocat
président de la commission nationale
consultative des droits de l'homme cinq
ans après cette loi qui notamment parmi
d'autres mesures mais en tout cas celle
ci pénalise les clients des prostituées
on s'aperçoit que le bilan est un peu
mitigé quel est le bilan que vous en
tirez vous est ce que vous vous êtes
surpris par ce que disent ces
travailleuses du sexe ou pas du tout non
je vais je vais vous dire la position de
la commission nationale consultative des
droits de l'homme la cncdh vous remercie
de m'inviter la commission est un organe
indépendant qui donne son avis dès 2014
nous avions rendu un avis donc avant la
loi 2016 sur la question et nous avions
pris une problématique qui permettait
d'une part de protéger en priorité les
mineurs donc la prostitution des mineurs
doit être protégé de toute façon et
d'éviter une pénalisation systématique
car nous voyons ce qui vient d'être dit
effectivement à trop vouloir bien faire
on a rendu plus difficile la situation
de certaines personnes
pénaliser les clients c'est bien mais la
pénalisation extrême rendait difficile
certaines positions notamment de
prostitution deux majeurs qui se disent
indépendants qui le sont ou pas et qui
se trouve dans une saison très délicate
en réalité
les mineurs devaient être protégés
complètement l'abolition du délit de
racolage passif également était une
bonne chose car vous savez bien que dans
un passé ancien la prostitution n'a
jamais été un délit et seul le racolage
l'été actif d'abord puis passif dont il
y avait eu une amélioration mais on est
sur une ligne de crête où avec notamment
les l'idée est de dire il faut être
libre de son corps et de permettre à
certaines personnes apparemment
indépendante de vouloir se livrer à la
prostitution les rendaient dans une des
méthodes une situation impossible
délicate
donc effectivement le bilan de la loi de
2016 cinq ans après reste mitigé mais
est un problème extrêmement difficile à
résoudre il va y avoir des tableaux
auront sur le sujet au sénat donc ça n'a
pas fini d'avancé en tout cas la
commission nationale consultative des
droits de l'homme est aussi très
attentive aux textes qui sont passés par
le sénat ces derniers mois parlons
d'abord de la loi sécurité globale
adoptée définitivement à la mi avril
il est censée mieux protéger les forces
de l'ordre je vous en redonne quelques
mesures phares création d'un délit de
provocation à l'identification des
forces de l'ordre et de leurs proches
port d'armes en dehors du service
déploiement de drones dans un cadre
légal bien défini accès élargi aux
images de vidéosurveillance exploitation
des images issues des caméras piétons
pouvoirs étendus pour la police
municipale suppression des réductions de
peine pour les détenus condamnés pour
violences contre les forces de l'ordre
est-ce que selon vous jean marie
burguburu et selon la commission
nationale consultative des droits de
l'homme cette loi préserve les libertés
ou pas nous avons rendu sur cette loi à
l'époque où il était encore en
proposition de loi un avis le 26
novembre
2020 car c'est bien sur des sujets qui
nous préoccupent
dans son principe une telle loi je ne
dis pas être attentatoire aux libertés
mais impact nécessairement les libertés
pour avoir plus de sécurité
on emprunte un peu un chemin qui touche
aux libertés et nous avons estimé que
certaines mesures étaient effectivement
un peu trop lourde
un peu trop intrusive sur les libertés
des citoyens par exemple évidemment la
question de la surveillance par drones
n'est ce pas des manifestations part
d'un bon principe ces drones existent
ils sont munis de tels objectifs
extrêmement puissant et avec cet
objectif
on peut par exemple surveiller la
circulation c'est une très bonne chose
mais à l'intérieur d'une manifestation
on voit non seulement les mouvements de
foule mais on peut voir bien sûr la
physionomie des participants la
physionomie des manifestants s'il se
livre à des infractions
c'est peut-être une bonne chose mais le
droit de manifester est une liberté
constitutionnelle
il ne faut donc pas qu'un tel moyen soit
dissuasif pour des personnes de
manifester paisiblement ce qui est
souhaitable librement et éventuellement
contre le gouvernement il est rare qu'on
manifeste en faveur légalement ça arrive
de temps en temps donc voyez vous les
moyens peuvent être bons mais ils sont
dangereux aussi
mais que faites vous du danger pour les
policiers vous dites on est attaché
évidemment libertés des citoyens les
policiers sont des citoyens aussi et
leur liberté d'exercer leur métier
de la manière la plus sécurisée possible
est plus qu'un droit
je veux dire ici qu'il est absolument
consternant pour dire qu'il n'est pas
scandaleux de voir que les policiers
sont en danger et les policiers sont là
pour protéger les citoyens la force
publique est une institution qu'est
prévu déjà par la déclaration des droits
de l'homme de 1789 la force publique est
nécessaire maintenant on en arrive
actuellement autant que nous vivons à
une situation où c'est la force publique
est en danger
elle est en danger parce que les
citoyens certains pas tous bien sûr ne
respecte plus le principe même d'une
force publique
une force publique qui fait son travail
qui fait des investigations qui fait des
mesures de protection alors l'idée
d'empêcher les policiers les forces de
l'ordre en général d'être filmés ou
photographiés est une idée extrêmement
difficile à mettre en oeuvre on se
souvient du débat qui a été entraînée
par le fameux article 84 du projet de
loi qui a changé de numérotation depuis
sept ans cette numérotation paraissant
dangereuse en définitive
et vous savez qu'une
commission présidée par jean marie
delarue qui mon prédécesseur à la
présidence de la commission nationale
consultative des droits de l'homme vient
de rendre un rapport de 160 pages avec
plus de 60 recommandations pour faire en
sorte que les relations entre la presse
et les citoyens en général mais la
presse notamment et les forces de
l'ordre soit apaisée soit compris parce
que c'est fou ce qui se passe on a
l'impression qu'il ya deux camps qui
s'opposent avec des pros police et des
antilles policiers et à ce drame qui
vient de toucher de frapper la police
nationale encore un policier tué avignon
policier de 36 ans tué par balles hier
en fin d'après midi près d'un point de
deals et gérald darmanin a parlé
carrément de guerre contre les
trafiquants de drogue et c'est terrible
ce hasard de calendrier mais hier le
journal libération faisait le choix
d'une une sur les violences dites
policière avec cette photo est ce titre
choc de ce jeune homme qui a perdu son
oeil après un tir de lb des tirs de l bd
les images qui accable la police on en
est là aujourd'hui on a deux camps
irréconciliables ya forcément un camp
qui déteste la police ait un qui le
défend c'est comme quand comment vous
qui défendez les droits de l'homme
voyez-vous ce ce débat qui est en train
de s'installer alors je vais être très
clair pour qu'il n'y a pas d'ambiguïté
la cncdh jeudi l'acronyme de la
commission nationale d'enquêté tiralos
ne déteste pas la police bien au
contraire je veux vous dis je vous ai
dit que la police était nécessaire pour
l'exercice des libertés
mais le problème est celui non pas des
dérives policières mais des dérives de
manifestation une manifestation dans le
calme
n'entraîne aucune difficulté ni pour les
manifestants ni pour les commerçants qui
ont leurs vitrines et les banques ou les
cafés ou les magasins de toutes sortes
qui ont leurs vitrines sur le parcours
de la manifestation et la police regarde
est passé s'il ya des déprédations
elle intervient vous savez bien que
désormais les manifestations hélas ne se
passe plus comme cela il y a d'une part
des personnes extérieures la
manifestation qui jette le trouble
les fameux black blocks et du coup un
entraînement à d'autres personnes qui ne
voulaient pas sans doute manifesté une
manière brutale
au départ et qui sont entraînés qui
voient comme les black box le fond il
dira on peut faire la même chose mais il
ya la police qui doit répliquer
nécessairement par conséquent la
situation est beaucoup plus difficile
qu'il y a 10 ans 20 ans ou 30 ans on se
souvient qu'il y avait eu de
manifestation a séduit en 1968 du moins
où les plus anciens s'en souviennent
mais on n'est pas allé aux extrémités où
nous sommes actuellement il faut donc
effectivement c'est malheureux de le
dire mais c'est nécessaire que la police
soit protégé mais ces protections ne
doit pas entamer les libertés c'est à
dire d'une part la liberté de manifester
qui reste constitutionnel et qui doit
être protégée et d'autre part la liberté
d'informer or l'information si elle est
principalement aux mains des organes de
presse des journalistes qui sont sur le
terrain et se nourrit aussi également
actuellement des photos des films et que
chaque citoyen peut prendre grâce à son
téléphone équipé d'une caméra un
appareil de photo et cela on ne peut pas
l'interdire en soi
donc ce qui est interdit ce n'est pas
les photographier les films c'est le
mauvais usage de ses films autrement dit
se servir d'une photo ou d'un film pour
les poursuivre un policier pour révéler
son identité pour révéler son domicile
éventuellement et pour arriver un des
drames comme on les connaît trop souvent
comme on les a vues récemment
l'autre texte qui est passé entre les
mains des sénateurs récemment c'est
celui qui veut lutter contre le
séparatisme le sénat l'a d'ailleurs
beaucoup durci les discussions avec
l'assemblée nationale risque d'être un
peu houleuse je vous donne la version du
sénat même si c'est pas forcément ce qui
sera retenu
interdiction du port du voile pour les
parents accompagnant les sorties
scolaires lors des compétitions
sportives nationales pour les mineurs
dans l'espace public interdiction du
burkini à la piscine suspension des
allocations familiales pour lutter
contre l'absentéisme à l'école et
instructions à domicile sur simple
déclaration plutôt que soumis à
autorisation
comment vous jugez ces mesures alors le
sénat joue son rôle
le sénat donne son opinion et sur
l'opinion et parfois souvent peut-être
est différente
de celle de l'assemblée nationale et
dans la situation politique que dans
laquelle nous sommes actuellement il ya
donc une surenchère du sénat elle est
légitime nous sommes dans un système
bicamérisme bicaméral avec les deux
assemblées
la cncdh bien c'est bien sûr préoccuper
de la question elle a rendu deux avis
sur la question un avis le premier et
dès le 28 janvier dernier et l'autre
tout récemment le 25 mars
voyez que nous sommes dans l'actualité
alors là encore c'est une question de
mesure et les nouvelles dispositions
prises par le sénat n'ont pas pu les
examiner encore nous les égales ont
peut-être peut-être offert un troisième
avis sur cette loi c'est toi qui
s'appelait avant vous vous en souvenez
loi contre le séparatisme et qui a pris
un nom plus modérée en quelque sorte
plus discret de confortant les principes
de la république
les principes d'un public sont fragiles
ils sont peut-être en danger et c'est
peut-être nécessaire de les conforter
mais là encore ils font les conforter
avec soin et ne pas risquer de les
atteindre en vouloir
en voulant faire trop bien alors des
mesures précises sur l'interdiction du
voile dans l'espace public pose un
problème de la laïcité on sait que le
voile est interdit notamment à l'école
mais qu'il est permis à l'université et
dans l'espace public
ce qu'interdit interdit c'est de le
masquer complètement le visage autrement
dit la burqa style afghanistan dont
l'interdiction du port du voile dans
l'espace public a priori vous dites
c'est une atteinte à la liberté
alors c'est une atteinte à la fois à la
liberté et à la laïcité
de l'état qui respecte les religions
l'état ne se mêle pas de religion mais
les respecte cela pose donc un problème
la vérité et pour les sénateurs comme
pour d'autres parties de la population
de savoir s'il y a un danger pour
l'image générale de la france si il y a
trop de personnes voilées dans l'espace
public
on oublie que il y à de nombreuses
dizaines d'années il y avait beaucoup de
religieuses voilées en france ça n'est
plus la même chose puisque maintenant il
s'agit de personnes privées ne s'agit
pas de ministres du culte
la question est posée à cause de la
question plus générale de l'intégration
on dit plus d'assimilation maintenant
mais d'intégration est ce que les
personnes voient les leçons de leur
plein gré si elles le sont est ce que
pour autant elle s'intègre bien dans
l'espace français où elle souhaite vivre
donc il ya tout une question qui est à
la fois juridique et philosophique sur
cette question ce ne sont pas des
questions qui se résolvent par un oui ou
pour un non
parlons du contexte sanitaire si vous
lui est bien qui a poussé des autorités
à nous mettre sous état d'urgence ça n'a
échappé à personne
on va bientôt en sortir en tout cas
officiellement à partir du 2 juin un
régime juridique transitoire va prendre
la suite concrètement ça veut dire que
pendant cinq mois
le chef du gouvernement en l'occurrence
jean castex pourra toujours si la
situation épidémique le justifie limiter
la circulation des personnes
interdire les transports aérien fermé
certains types d'établissements et
conditionner les déplacements français à
l'étranger à la présentation d'un test
pcr ou d'une attestation de vaccination
est ce que vous vous dites ce soir c'est
normal vu le contexte où vous trouvez ça
encore trop eh bien je vais vous dire
que ce qui arrive nous l'avions prévu
depuis l'état d'urgence sanitaire la
cncdh a rendu au moins deux avis 1 le 28
avril
1 le 26 mai et 2 déclaration une le 23
juin et une autre le 26 novembre tout ça
de l'année 2020 nous sommes donc sur la
question et nous avons prévu notamment
le risque qu'ils arrivent à savoir que
quand l'état d'urgence se termine et je
ne fais pas d'humour l'état d'urgence
continuent à quoi sert-il de dire que
l'état d'urgence se termine
si on laisse au premier ministre dont je
respecte la personne et la
responsabilité la possibilité de prendre
des mesures qui relèvent de l'état
d'urgence autant dire que l'état
d'urgence se poursuit et d'ailleurs
peut-être est-il nécessaire qu'il se
poursuive jusqu'à l'extinction complète
de la pandémie et ses textes action
complète on ne la connaît pas même si on
avance vers une sécurité plus grande
avec la vaccination si j'ai enlevé mon
masque c'est que je suis vacciné deux
fois alors si vous voulez je ne dis pas
que cette mesure est liberticide et je
pense que le terme liberticide doit être
réservé à des mesures qui tue la liberté
ce n'est pas le cas la france n'est pas
en dictature
mais la france en état d'urgence
sanitaire
autre chose que l'état d'urgence anti
terroristes que nous avons connus ou la
france risque de rester dans cet état
d'urgence autrement dit où des pouvoirs
sont donnés à l'exécutif ce qui empiète
sur le pouvoir normalement dévolue au
législatif donc à l'assemblée nationale
et au sénat que je remercie de m'avoir
invité
si ces mesures sont encore entre les
mains du pouvoir exécutif alors disons
le plus simplement l'état d'urgence
hélas se poursuit peut-être avec moins
de mesures mais encore des mesures il
nous reste très peu de temps je sais que
vous êtes aussi très mobilisé sur la
situation des migrants notamment à
calais est ce que en quelques mots vous
pouvez nous expliquer ce qui se passe là
bas ce qui se passe là bas est terrible
il est facile de dire ces migrants nous
ennuie ces migrants viennent envahir la
france ce n'est pas vrai il y à des
migrants bien sûr il ya une pression
migratoire forte c'est certain mais ce
le callet notamment la plupart de ceux
de calais souhaite ne pas rester en
france
il souhaite aller de l'autre côté de la
manche aller en grande bretagne or la
situation depuis le bric site est
beaucoup plus difficile qu'avant nous
avons fait une mission en décembre
dernier à calais et je retournerai à
calais avec une délégation de la cncdh
lundi 17 mai lundi à huit pourquoi parce
que la dégradation de la situation des
migrants bloqués à calais ou à grande
synthe est aggravée par les décisions
des autorités locales qu'il s'agisse du
maire de calais de la merde là madame la
maire de calais ou du préfet du
département sur les difficultés plus
grandes de plus en plus forte
opposés aux personnes qui rendent des
services humanitaires
il ne s'agit pas pour l'instant on n'en
est pas encore là
d'intégrer ces populations à la france
il s'agit de leur apporter une situation
conforme au minimum des droits de
l'homme de la dignité que la france qui
se prétend et qui est je l'espère la
patrie des droits de l'homme se doit
d'apporter à ces migrants ce ne sont pas
des français il ne veut pas rester en
france mais ils sont sur le sol national
il faut qu'ils puissent quand même se
nourrir pouvoir éventuellement à voir
les siens les soins d'hygiène minimum
cela actuellement est de plus en plus
difficile voire parfois impossible
ça ne peut pas rester comme ça et
l'avertissement est lancé merci
infiniment jean marie burguburu d'avoir
été avec nous ce soir